la belgique est en fait elle célèbre son
héros tintin souffle aujourd'hui ses 75
bougies
de nombreuses manifestations sont
organisées dans le pays natal du célèbre
reporter créé par hergé à bruxelles
frédéric vian patrick johnston tintin a
beau être une star absolument
internationale il a pourtant bel et bien
une patrie et c'est ici à bruxelles ou
plutôt sous bruxelles que le reporter
globe-trotter et chez lui jusque sur les
quais et dans les couloirs du métro de
la ville dont il orne les murs avec ses
compagnons depuis 1986 en surface à deux
pas de la grand-place tintin a aussi sa
boutique la seule au monde à être
officiellement reconnue et que l'on
vient donc visité du monde entier et
dans toutes les langues
ainsi au brésil notre héros s'appelle
quant aux ducs ou en espagnol manos quoi
qu'il en soit la passion tintinophiles
peut vite coûter presque aussi cher que
les bijoux de la castafiore
étant donné le prix des vêtements
accessoires et autres statuettes
ça peut finir par poser un réel problème
quand on a par exemple deux enfants
habillés bon temps passe et indémodable
et
c'est vrai qu'on y laisse quand même
quelques quelque argent mais forte pour
les enfants on peut bien faire ça à
quelques centaines de mètres de là
tintin est aussi la star du musée belge
de la bande dessinée
ici on a beau s'intéresser à toute la bd
francophone c'est tout de même le petit
reporter à houppette qui se distingue et
qui entraîne derrière lui les dizaines
de personnages secondaires
créé par région il ya un côté madeleine
de brochure est un enjeu souvient de
lecture enfants parce qu'on n'a pas
nécessairement toutes les bandes
dessinées est donc atteinte un oui c'est
la première demande de visiteurs au
centre belge de la bande dessinée pour
son anniversaire
tintin s'est aussi offert une réédition
de l'alfa dernier album de la série
un album inachevé